hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast using CRISPR and stem cells to
treat genetic disease presented by Bruce
Conklin senior investigator Gladstone
Institute of cardiovascular disease
professor department of medicine
division of genomic medicine and
University of California San Francisco
I'm Alexis Krause of laberd's and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bringing this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left you screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Conklin I will
now turn the presentation over to him
hello this is Bruce Conklin and it's a
pleasure to be here I'm going to be
talking about using CRISPR first in stem
cells to treat genetic disease I'd like
to just start with a conflict of
interest statement I'm involved in
several companies as indicated here and
then every and nonprofit organizations I
also would like to start with my eye
list of the contributors people who
contributed to this project or in
particular the ones in yellow both
people in my laboratory as well as
recent alumni and then
importantly the collaborators who
provide us with critical tools and and
advice along these projects I think my
my lab actually works between two
combining two disruptive technologies
and remarkably they're they're just a
really bookmarked by two different
papers as indicated here one in two
thousand six twelve years ago and then
two thousand twelve the invention of of
CRISPR and it's these people and the
technologies which are illustrated here
where we work in the sense that we take
IPS cells and we make them as use them
as models of human disease and then we
use CRISPR to test hypotheses about
disease within IPS cells and then more
recently using CRISPR to see whether or
not we can use CRISPR as a tool for
actually curing some of these diseases
so it's between these two technologies
and the intersection that we work the
most so why use IPS cells and these are
the stem cells that we work on primarily
because they can make many different
types of tissue that were just
inaccessible before my my lab in
particular works with making neurons
like that arm for instance motor neurons
as well as I'll tell you about our
project with retinal pigment epithelium
and we've also worked with cardiac
muscle these cells and the other ones
listed here were just inaccessible from
defined humans with with with disease
and it's these sorts of cells which are
really provide a dramatic setting for us
now to proceed and ask questions about
disease when the the IP
themselves themselves can not only be
directly differentiated to one
particular type of cell but it's also
using organoid cultures where cells are
now allowed to to grow as a complete as
a complete tissue we now have many other
tissues that we can work in such as the
mini brains and and hearts and vessels
and things like that so this area is
progressing very rapidly now I'd like to
just talk to you about two different
models of of modeling human disease one
is two on the left is the type which is
the the most common we used in in the
world and that's essentially to collect
us fibroblasts or cells from different
patients and then to have you the
different patients such as one through
six six being in the red here where you
you can make disease IPS cells and then
you can compare those and to see in
diverse populations how those cells
behave
you can even correct those different IPS
cells and and and and that has been
informative however that because they
come from diverse populations the mutant
lines even if they're say variants of
mutants and the exact same gene can't be
compared directly to each other because
they have different genetic backgrounds
in contrast one can make a nice agenda
curious on the on the right as
illustrated on the right with this WTC
listed WTC is the wild-type C Line that
we actually have provided to the
community and is actually now becoming
sort of a common platform for studying
human disease but one can do this with
any wild-type IPS cell and so if you
take a wild-type cell line like this and
now make an allelic series where you now
see multiple
versions of the same IP esse you can
make an allelic series of disease IPS
cells for instance make disease
mutations and what's different here is
that now you can take stay for instance
c1 and compare it directly with c6 and
you can say that are they are they
really different from each other on them
in a molecular manner with the
background completely controlled and so
one can actually now Cal the the
difference between subtle differences
between say mutations in the same gene
or the same type of disease this
actually making an isogenic series is
actually faster less expensive and
easier to reveal the mechanisms of
genetic interactions and they can
utilize common resources such as the
alan as a cell sciences as indicated
here which distributes many different
versions of this cell line so it's when
i say it's faster it's actually actually
about one fifth of the cost of doing the
same experiment using patient lines and
that's because especially if you want to
make a cell type the disease cell type
like cardiac myocytes like neurons that
every cell line will behave differently
and have slightly different phenotypes
just because of the genetic background
or is they should start off with a well
characterized IPS line it's much easier
to make that end tissue and that's
actually why it's so much easier to to
do and so the wild-type see in
particular but a many other kind of well
behaved cell lines you can have even
high school students essentially growing
these cells and really doing this
routinely and there's and so and that
makes everything a lot easier as a
result so this common platform for human
biology as wild-type see as i indicated
here before the reason that it's so
useful is that it has a stable karyotype
and is and is how stable pluripotent
there's over 100 mutant variants in both
in my lab and then the Allen Institute
with many others and there's many tool
lines that there's
induced Chris burgers per eye and the
genome is fully sequenced and is
available to academia and Industry the
line is also available publicly at the
Coryell and the and and why cell cell
banks and many academic cores as well
now one of the great advantages of this
line particularly with the Allen
Institute has been that they have now
actually labeled various different
structures and they're going to be
labeling over a hundred different
structures in the cells and so this is a
picture here of lamb and be tagged wild
type C cells and this is a complete lawn
of cells that is a cluster of cells but
only the nuclei are labeled and this is
very very powerful because in fact that
this these cells then no matter what
they do you can in terms of
differentiation you can always follow
this lamin be staining and they've
marked many other structures look for
instance structures in the cardiac cells
structures in many other areas interest
to cell biologists and this is an
incredibly useful resource now I'm going
to switch now to the second topic which
is how we actually think about not just
using IPS cells to decode disease but
how we think about using them as a model
for genome surgery to cure rare disease
this is all of this work is really in
close collaboration with with Jennifer
Doudna and her Institute the the
innovative genomics Institute so why do
I call it genome surgery in particular
and so I just would like to talk a
little bit about that name because it's
it does there's there's sort of many
meanings to that and one can think about
so the problem with approaching CRISPR a
disease with CRISPR is it most is
users require many different approaches
so there's in this bar graph this this
pie chart here we see actually actually
so that represents 7,000 diseases and
relatively few of these 7,000 diseases
are common mutations common mutations so
you can think about a gene drug one drug
that would actually be given a gene
vector that would be used in many many
people now those are obviously of great
importance there's no question about
that and the the pharmaceutical
companies and by tech companies are
pursuing those but the vast majority of
genetic disease is really not amenable
to the stay of that sort of standard
model and one thinks about a different
model perhaps to approach these rare
diseases and one can think about the
surgical model where every patient is
different and it's useful to think about
the surgical model because there's
different regulations different funding
different training that one would
actually use in a surgical model so I
just remind you that that really that
there's a really different types of
heritage and history for medicine versus
surgery and these different historical
origins are in the actual word
physicians and surgeons the Columbia the
School of Medicine for instance
positions and surgeons and they're come
from very different backgrounds
physicians of course are come from the
tradition of prescribing different types
of medicines for people where surgeons
are really I have always been associated
with sharp knives and being able to cut
things out but the difference goes
beyond that in the sense that the that
traditionally medicine thinks about
using drugs to cure a disease and
billion-dollar drugs which are obviously
also very important wares
surgery takes on each person as a rare
disease and has it takes a different
surgical approach and so for instance
when people did the first heart
transplants they were just happy that
the patient survived but they weren't
actually thinking about how to monetize
the 10th heart transplant they were
actually thinking about the next way
that they could do it better and each
time in an iterative process these
processes got better and perhaps I'm
postulating that the genome surgery for
these rare diseases will add up together
so that eventually that we will be able
to approach genetic disease somewhat
like a surgeon where different patients
are have different remedies and so when
we think about genome surgery as well in
terms of in terms of anatomical terms on
the right you can see think about
restoration and particularly you think
about a single base pair of change from
an A to a G or insertion where you
actually could insert a piece of DNA as
shown in the center or one could think
about excision where say there's a
diseased part as represented by the red
area area and now that that actually can
be potentially removed and it turns out
that in non-dividing cells that this is
by far the easiest to do with CRISPR and
so we actually focus on excision as a
therapeutic a mode because it's just
stunning how efficient this can be in
certain cell types we see over 80% of
the cells where we have a precise
excision just at the right place and
this is not just for what we're doing
but actually if you think about where
therapeutic the genome surgery has
already gone on it is used as excision
and so for instance the ccr5 knockout is
essentially an excision of part of the
gene the d repression of fetal
hemoglobin for sickle cell and
thalassemia is really the most
commonly pursued method of therapeutic
editing that is being used by a multiple
I think now over five biotech companies
and then the exon skipping of course
with Duchenne's muscular dystrophy also
uses excision to get that to really have
its its benefit so where we are right
now in terms of how we think about the
the genome surgery process is the is
I'll tell you about is sort of how we
think about choosing the disease as
shown as the arrow on the left and
really in about 2013 and that process
and then we actually chose a lot about
many different diseases but then we
chose a specific diseases that I'll tell
you about and then you have to find the
patients make IPS cells and then make
tissues to which is our current focus
and test the edits and I'll be telling
you about getting to that second arrow
and in some of our beginning test edits
so for proof of concept we we thought
about multiple different types of
therapy and tissues to work in the heart
on the left is actually what we'd worked
on before but we're focusing most of our
effort on the retina and motor neurons
as shown on the right and the reason
that we are is because there's there's
several advantages at least for proof of
concept studies certainly the heart is a
very important organ and they're the
diseases there are one that we would
like to address however there are five
billion cells in the heart and the the
dominant and also the types of disease
the genetics of the disease are not as
well understood as in the other organs
and then the risk of potentially having
a adverse effect if one were to treat
the heart
as much more severe so for proof of
concept studies it's less than ideal
in contrast the retina and the motor
neuron you can actually probably edit a
hundred thousand cells and see a
measurable effect I mean you probably
want to edit a lot more cells to cure
disease but do you have a mineral effect
because you can measure effects in these
cells is very important the other thing
is that you can have the dominant
negatives as I'll indicate later our
type of genetic mutation which is very
well characterized in retina and motor
neurons and the risk although
significant is is much less than the
heart so we're focusing on these tissues
primarily so that we can move the field
forward and do these types of a proof of
concept studies in addition we are
looking for not just a particular organ
but within that organ we have to think
about how which would be the disease
course that you would ultimately want if
you were to design a trial and so for
instance in the bar on the Box on the
Left we can see that there are in fact
and this is a disease course which
starts early so you can identify the
patients and then as they progress in
years
the patients continue to get worse so
there is a progression of disease but
they don't they don't get worse suddenly
and so having this predictable
type of decrease is something which is
advantageous so that one can in fact
perhaps intervene and by making an
intervention as indicated by this white
arrow that if at any time if we can make
a change that we can then see an effect
and we would know that we've done
something positive whereas this is in
contrast to the middle air time course
where we actually see
that the disease waxes and wanes and
with a waxing and waning it's very
difficult to know at any time if our
intervention is what caused the change
or whether this is just the natural
disease course and so although these
other diseases such as this such as
fairies as this kind of represents an
ALS course we these disease are
incredibly important but at the same
time they're very difficult to do proof
of concept studies whenever we can that
also our tool of choice is the are cast
9r NP which is the RNA cast 9 protein
complex or our NP this is a DNA free
genome scalpel and this is very powerful
particularly in the eye where the this
protein complex can be readily taken up
the advantage of this is it causes the
least possible risk to the patient
because the cast 9 is a protein which
actually degrades within less than a day
in most cases and will and is complex to
a guide RNA which is also thin synthetic
this reduces the costs of the material
which goes into the patient and also and
it reduces the risk because there's no
DNA involved there's no DNA that can be
integrated into the patient these this
is particularly important because the
cast 9 is a bacterial product and as a
bacterial product is known to cause
immune responses in humans and so
therefore you don't really want the
bacterial product to be around for a
long period of time
cast 9 RMP can be is they're rapidly
degraded and therefore we can suppress
for a short period of time but you don't
have to worry about long very now the
disease that we're focused on the most
in the eye is a disease called best one
best
is as a model system and is a disease
which is proven dominant-negative
mutations causing blindness and
allele-specific activation it's called
best one actually because doctor best
described it over a hundred years ago
but it's also we consider to be very
aptly named best one because it really
is the best for modeling this type of
genome surgery its target tissue is RPE
that can be grown from a patient's IPS
cells and the RPE preferentially takes
up casts nine RMP there's a gradual
progression of the disease and the
treatment outcomes can be measured
festro Fionn and best disease is occurs
in the RPE which are shown in the as the
blue cells and the blue cells as
indicated below have embedded in them
the photoreceptors the photoreceptors
slough off every 10 days and as eaten by
the antagonistic host by the RPE and so
this RPE is a professional phagocytosis
a machine that takes up protein lipid
complex and essentially that's what
we're going to be feeding the cells when
we give them cast line RMT the protein
lipid complex and so so targeting is
really driven by the by the fact that
the cells can be the preferentially take
up this complex now best row friend is a
chloride channel which sits on the
surface membrane of the cell causing
somehow contributing to the phagocytosis
and process and when the best Ropin is a
disease then you get a lack of
phagocytosis and that's what seems to be
a sort correlated with the disease so
the way we think about dominant negative
alleles is that if we have this is
indicated here with the structure of
the best protein that's one protein you
can see here that it's a homo pentamer
that is made by the best one protein and
you have 50% of it coming from either
the healthy or the dominant negative
protein and in this case you can see
that in some cases only one subunit is
taken up by the best one dominant
negative allele or sometimes all of it
but in any case these these these
channels are now inactive and so even
though only 50% of the protein is
causing is disease-causing because it's
this homo pentamer 97% of the of the
Penta Murs are poisoned in one way or
the other
so essentially the the phenotype of this
disease of the severe types of mutants
are in fact very similar to a patient
with a knockout of best-of-the-best
protein so the we have have a mechanism
that we think is there and obviously
what we would like to do then is to be
able to remove and eliminate the
dominant negative a wheel to potentially
cure the disease and if we remove the
dominant negative allele as shown by
these red x's then only the healthy
protein would be made and we could
theoretically cure the disease but how
do we know that this would work that
only one copy of the gene would actually
be sufficient for normal visual function
well fortunately human genetics the
excellent human genetics in the eye
actually gives us the answer
there are actually humans maybe some of
the people that are listening to this
presentation now actually only have one
copy of best one which is functioning
and that one copy is shown to be is
known to completely healthy and
completely have completely normal vision
and
we know that they have normal vision is
that some unfortunate people who have
only one useful copy of best one then
have children with another person who
has only one copy and they have children
with unfortunately no best Rovin and
those the children have severe versions
of best disease but now we know for sure
when we go and examine the the parents
that those parents have absolutely
normal vision and therefore essentially
the experiment has already been done for
us so if we can with CRISPR now go in
and take out just the diseased version
of the of the the gene with CRISPR we
should have a healthy healthy subjects
the other disease that we're working on
is the charcot-marie-tooth disease or
CMD as a model system it has proven
dominant-negative mutations crippling
disease that and we can use this to test
a real specific editing particularly in
motor neurons motor neurons can be grown
from patients and IPS cells and I'll
show you some pictures of those and you
can deliver the cast 9 RMP components
but it's unfortunately the Cassadine RMP
it's going to be a bit challenging so we
may have to use viruses and take
advantage of the tremendous research
that other people have done to make
viruses that can actually target the
motor neurons the there's gradual
progression of disease and the treatment
outcomes can be measured the sense that
you can actually directly talk when you
target someone's motor neurons you and
if you make those motor neurons better
it's a very we know exactly what motor
neurons do and we test that by motor
function so the charcot-marie-tooth
- is the type that we're most interested
in right now and that's because they
have clear dominant negative genetics
and the dominant negative genetics are
exactly the same as the dominant
negative genetics that we were showing
or similar to the ones before in other
words that they the mutations in one
allele causes a disease and that a loss
of a complete loss of that allele is
completely compatible with normal
physiologic function so the genes that
we're working on here are shown as my
diffusion - they're a filament light
chain polypeptide each a protein 1 B and
the T RNA synthesis which are each can
cause can result in a type of motor
neuron disease a loss of motor neurons
sometimes they end up requiring a
wheelchair so the basic idea is that we
would like to be able to sequence this
is for the best one or for the other
types of or the shark Amriki that you'd
like to actually UK take the person who
has the disease to isolate that to just
sequence them and everybody will be
sequenced essentially in pretty fairly
soon that will be able to almost all the
patients will be seen and those and then
you'll be able to say okay so I see
where your mutation is that causes is
indicated by this this kind of fireball
here and I could say that if that
mutation and we may not have a cast 9
that targets that particular spot and a
lot of these dominant negatives have
many different spots that are that are
causing the disease and many different
mutations that cause the disease but we
could say you know what but your your
mutation
is insists in other words it is on this
on the same on the same chromosome as
say guide number B and number E and we
already have that and these the these
types of polymorphisms are actually very
common
so we're targeting the caste 9 to those
specific common alleles and then the
idea would be that we could then take me
and put them together and then to delete
the of the disease allele have the
normal intact the advantage of using the
common variants for excision is that the
that the won't have to make guides for
all the different rare mutations that
often occur dominant negative alleles
but we potentially could in fact have a
few a panel of pre-tested RMPs
or guides which actually allows us to
now this goes for as I said best one as
well as the chart for you now that now
of course we don't want to test this in
people without testing it in their cells
first and one of the great things about
the motor neurons as well as the RPE I
didn't have time to show you the RP but
we have beautiful RPE
going we have beautiful motor neurons
also growing from the IPS cells and as
indicated here we can actually show take
the IPS cells and in today's actually
make motor neurons and the way that we
make motor neurons from IPS cells is to
force Express transcription factors so
there are indicated here on this on this
diagram of a vector we have three
transcription factors as shown in red
and purple and each of these
transcription factors contribute to
making motor neurons when they're over
expressed together using the 10th system
we can get motor neurons in just a week
as in
here all the purple cells indicated here
are expressing a unique motor neuron a
specific protein we can do this in 96
well plate format or other types of play
formats and because this system has been
stable II infused into motor neurons we
can get them to grow essentially
on-demand and this greatly improves our
ability now to to model the system now
we have these cells or from a control
cell type wild-type see though we have
similar results now with other types of
cells for from patients for instance and
and indicated here we have also really
robust changes that are most obvious
when the cells are in years so on the
left is a 96-well plate and shown here
is a sphere of about two thousand cells
which are expressing now you can see the
arborization coming out of them take a
closer look at that arborization and say
here on the day 1 2 4 & 5 you can see
that after the induction of doxycycline
a rapid induction of these axons and
we're very excited about this we think
that this will allow us to grow tissue
which we can then cast and we're right
now in the process of the the cells that
have CM key and comparing them with and
without evidence so the steps in genome
surgery are just in summary are the that
we are currently focuses making the
tissue and sort of starting the edits
and we have very robust allele-specific
edits and we're sort of in the midst of
testing now hundreds of those on the
cell types that we have the major
challenges of course are quite
significant can we deliver Cassadine RMP
to the to the target tissue can we
utilize cell specific surface markers
well we have to use viruses can we
control maybe catheline activation of
the things controlling DNA repair for
small excisions or even larger sit-ins
are still largely unexplored the this is
this is an area of great research and we
are we're now tackling that and using
these clinical samples as a way to start
challenging our our very knowledge of
how DNA repair goes and happens in these
differentiated occasions this is studies
in cancer for her cancer cell lines but
not these differentiated tissues and
that's critical for our our experiment
to work obviously we want to move
towards clinical trials and clinical
trials will require us to have you know
being together a number of people
including clinicians regulatory affairs
people animal trials and so on and this
process is challenging but also
exhilarating because we really are
making progress on this front the do we
see genome surgery is a new standard of
care the long term goal is to make em
surgery standard of care in fact for as
a sustainable model and the surgical
model we believe is really a way to
express this and in a broad range of
types of diseases using of course these
very relatively rare types of disease
but I think that that's will provide the
foundation for something larger we can
also reduce the cost hopefully to save
money for society while reducing
suffering the expanded types of edits in
the clinic can only be done really with
these sort of test cases so for instance
allele-specific editing in a excision
setting targeted methylation are all
things which are things that we would
like to use for genome surgery future
but would be difficult to test in a
larger group until we've had these
certain test cases and some of the test
cases that I described today have a very
strong compelling reason for that the
the mechanisms of disease are also
incredibly important because we can
actually really by by doing these edits
we're actually testing the mechanism and
we can test to see whether or not this
can actually cause you don't really know
the mechanism for most disease and just
by doing the editing we actually are
proving at that point for April to
further casing this gene is causative in
fact and it can in fact really
potentially be reversed so in summary I
think that we have a careful choice
we're really at the beginning of this
adventure I don't think that this by no
means a sort of finished story we have
careful choice of the disease targets we
have two diseases that are types general
types of diseases that were working and
that's one and then several genes within
seventy and then I talked a bit about
genome surgery and future directions and
so with that I at the end of my time and
and ready to take questions Thank You
dr. Conklin for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen and click the send button
our speaker will follow up with your
questions via email so let's get started
our first question is
what do you think genome surgery will
look like ten years from now well I
think it's a very good question I think
that the it will definitely be quite
different in the sense that certainly
there will be clinical trials that have
proceeded both for relatively relatively
common diseases such as sickle cell and
thalassemia and so we'll know for a
proof of concept that whether or not
these type of editing can be used to
treat disease and this will be important
because these are incurable diseases
that will have potentially a permanent
sort of solution for furthermore those
are those are the ones that are in this
or in the commercial realm in the non
commercial realm in the academic realm
we'll be taking on a much wider variety
of diseases and there'll be clinical
trials in best fit specifically in the
retina and nervous system for a wide
variety of diseases and this is going to
be incredibly helpful and for a number
of patients because these are also
diseases that are are without any cure
and they have at this point there's
there's no really no hope of finding a
medicine but now with this new therapy
that we could treat a much larger group
of people so even though each of these
diseases are very rare the fact that as
a sum there's many more of them and that
will have a bigger impact on the overall
population the I think that will be
moving from the proof-of-concept stages
where we're trying to actually make
focusing on diseases which have like
like I say they're the lowest risk and
and the highest impact to areas where we
can actually go to higher risk
situations such as in the cardiac system
we can be going into perhaps competing
with other types of therapies for
instance with transplants for instance
so in heart transplants are or kidney
transplant or kidney or liver
transplants right now most of the time
people would choose to have a transplant
if they need such as such a therapy but
as the technology becomes safer I
imagine that it be used in in those
settings as well and then a wider
variety of Eva's can be treated there as
well so so I think yet though that's the
and so I think it's going to become
getting moving towards sort of a
standard of care in certain diseases and
then as a research tool a much wider
group of diseases and a 10-year horizon
and gradually those experimental
therapies will then be going turning
into you standard it here at our next
question do you think genome surgery
will be too expensive
well I think that too expensive is a is
a is a difficult sort of thing to define
but I do think that and a certainly
concern for people is that that this is
a therapy which would be really
unattainable by many people but in fact
there's really nothing that expensive
about the technology so for instance a
cast 9r NP in particular the cost of
goods for going in to somebody without
the medical
cost I mean that position costs or
anything like that is actually quite low
we're just talking about a recombinant
protein and a-and and the end the
synthetic RNA and then with some lipid
and around it so there's really no
reason that it needs to be an expensive
therapy of course the research and
development will be potentially
expensive but that's something that we
can hopefully try to cover the land
through here are other purposes so it's
possible that at a genome surgery itself
for certain settings actually could be
reasonably priced and in fact especially
when you think about the cost of
blindness cost of having someone be
crippled and so on
that would be much less than the those
costs and burdens on society so I think
that when compared say for instance to a
heart transplant or or other types of
major surgical procedures this actually
could be on the lower end of the costs
as as we as we move forward I would like
to once again thank dr. Conklin for his
presentation I would also like to thank
laberd's for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through January of 2019 you won't
receive an email from laberd's letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now thank you for joining us and we
hope to see you again soon goodbye